I've got an object I've got a body it
has a known mass I know how fast it's
going when it starts off and where it's
not signing now here's an interesting
this is why I had to be a bit vague with
this language here okay
resistance is proportional to now this
bit here will change okay I give you a
classic example when it comes to water
resistance through water is roughly
proportional to speed
full-stop okay but depending on the meme
that you're going through sometimes the
resistance will be proportional not to
the speed but to the square of the speed
or to other things in our case we're
really not going to see anything further
than V squared okay you either be
proportional to velocity or to the
square of the velocity but you need to
watch out for that okay now in this case
what we're going to try and work toward
is an equation for the velocity in terms
of displacement where I am okay so you
look at this have a think where might
you begin
it might help if you have a think
carefully in terms of the language we
already know and the pronumerals you
already know about what information you
have and where you're trying to go so
you have an M right you have a
particular value of V right now you have
a resistance you have a resistance now
when it comes to all of the different
quantities that you know what is your
assistance about what is it describing
and the answer is it's a force right so
I know something about a force here
right so being that I'm going to go to
velocity I know a force I know something
about the force and I know a mess this
is gonna feed pretty nicely into that
place we seem to start a lot which is MA
so this is where I'm going to begin the
moral of the story is if you never know
what to do you got no clues just start
there you might get something useful
okay so here's what I've got the
resistance is proportional to the square
of the speed now let me write this as an
equation okay the way that I would say
this formally is that F is proportional
to dude that's um it's not an alpha and
looks a lot like an alpha but it's not
if you're writing alpha no one will
complain but F is proportional to the
square of the speed so that's this way
okay so if something is proportional to
something else
right then what distinguishes them is a
constant of some kind okay it's like oh
I'm always twice as big or I'm always
half the size or always you get the idea
so I don't know what K is but doesn't
matter okay
so therefore what I'm gonna put in here
is K V squared now hot understanding I'm
gonna pause before I go any further okay
forces have direction don't they okay so
even though this is a statement about
magnitude right this statement in here
huh
doesn't make any con about which way
it's that magnitude is facing right
which way do you think it should face
now I want it to be because it's
resistance right I want it to be
opposing the direction that the motion
is it now there's no definition at all
really about what's positive and what's
they did but it sort of makes sense to
just call whichever direction you're
going in positive okay so we'll call
that the positive direction which means
that this really should be minus kV
square it's gonna have that effect of
reducing you okay good I know what the
mass is
and then I've got acceleration okay
excellent
so now us got a starting point stuck
some stuff in where shall I go from here
where am i trying to go to I want to get
to V as a function of X right so that
gives your big clue as to how you should
rewrite acceleration you've got a couple
of different choices okay what are they
you could go
you could go well that's um sorry let's
get the acceleration on tone first so
I've got minus K square okay you could
go V DV DX okay now that's a great
candidate in this particular case
because you're gonna be over here and
you've got these here as well so you can
get all these and make things even
simpler right okay all right so I'm
going to divide through by V which means
that at this point now we are implying a
restriction namely velocity cop easier
okay now have a look at this
where do we go from here okay these are
always the points at which you need to
stop and think I have a problem I have a
province right I want to get to velocity
right and so it seems like a good thing
to have a DV up there because when I
integrate I'll get a V on that side the
problem with this though is that this is
differentiating with respect to X right
but I don't have any X variables over
here so I can't really integrate this
right hand side with respect to X so
what should I do
I should flip right if I make it with
respect to V I'll flip that off that
this side as well so that looks like
it's going to be minus 5 over K V okay
so far so good so now that I have it all
in terms of V I can actually integrate
you're going to integrate everything
okay with respect to you get an x over
there and then that my time okay okay
it's just the constant I probably should
have mentioned that here should burn
okay so therefore you have your minus 5
over K here your 1 over V DV there all
right
what's the integral it's log good now
it's indefinite so I have some constant
flying around
okay no hmm this is not really what I
want is this this is not what I want I
I'm after an equation for V in terms X
and I've got an equation for x in terms
of V but that's okay
all I need to do is rearranges and get
the inverse enormous fine what do i do
at this point
gotta get rid of that cluster okay I can
use this initial condition right because
initial doesn't just mean T equals 0 I
might as well just say well start at the
origin right x equals 0 okay so now I
have some values I have a V value 8 and
I have an X value that I can put into
this okay so we're settled in
okay there you go so now I can bring
this back into my displacement equation
x equals and it looks a bit gross with
all of these log terms hanging around
but it's not so bad right what can I do
I've got heaps a lot more I can use
right now have a look at this thing
watch out for that minus sign what
should I do maybe I'll take out a factor
of five on K first right and this is
positive this is the thing to do so I
have log eight minus log 10 right look
at again now here's the thing that's
gonna end up with when I put these
together with my log laws right when you
subtract you're going to have 8 over V
that's kind of a pain but because I want
to end up with V okay so instead of that
what I'm gonna do is I might just slap
this minus sign here at the front and
that will reverse the order of my logs
okay that's gonna become this v8 okay
this is minus 5 over K log and he is my
role in that
so now I'm just a couple of steps away I
need to get that log by itself so I kick
these guys over at the other side looks
to me like I'll get - kx5 okay so far so
good
almost done how do I rewrite this thing
V on 8 equals e to the minus K X on five
one last step to get to what I'm after
v equals multiply through and you're
like yeah ah it's exponential decay I'll
wait of course it's exponential decay
because what does exponential decay mean
it means you're yes I mean something is
reducing in this case it's velocity
something is slowing down right but as
you slow down the rate at which you slow
down it gets smaller right of course it
does because it's proportional to the
square of the speed so as you get slower
and slower and slower the resistance
also reduces right so you're never going
to get to m/s in this situation you're
never going to stop
fully okay because this thing is
asymptotic it zero okay